my name's sam draco i'm a farrier and
i'm going to show you the cleaning
process and the chewing process of a
horse
the main thing i'll do is ride in the
schools there's a lot more science
behind it than meets the eye so what you
would need is a anatomical sort of
understanding of the horse's foot with
tendons ligaments arteries veins bones
columns how they grow
also we need to have some blacksmithing
skills or just construct the shoe
anything that needs to be done to help
maintain the horse's lifespan really
so the actual condition of this foot is
is pretty good it's just been six weeks
and it's just grown
so that triangle bit in the middle was
known as the frog
this is
known for helping grip and aiding blood
supply around the foot
so i've got my straight blade and i'm
actually cleaning out the sole as you
can see it's of gonna crumble out
and then this will help me aiding in how
much foot this horse has actually grown
and i'll just trim it all back
as the hoof grows it's almost like a
giant fingernail so it's always
constantly growing so you need to trim
that back reset the shoe back
so the bone column of the structure of
the leg is actually set in the correct
place rather than if it's too long it
will be under a lot of pressure for an
attendant so imagine always wearing a
huge pair of shoes for yourself it makes
it very difficult for you to walk so to
have the horses regularly trimmed will
help actually maintain the lifespan of
the horse and the function of it doing
whatever discipline it's in
as you take the sole out it will start
to become slightly waxy it won't crumble
out quite so easy and that's a good
indication you're getting as far as you
should go and then you should be able to
just trim that bit off of the excess
hoof and that's it so you want to trim
from there really
so i'd use these giant peritoneal
cutters really and you'll just start
trimming the foot off nice and level as
flat as you can the bit i'm actually
trimming is exactly what a toenail made
out of so it's millions and millions of
strands of hair actually bonded together
so it's exactly the same keratin protein
as a fingernail would have
there is actually no nerve endings on
the bits that i touch the horse feels
the sensation so imagine having a shoe
on and somebody taps the bottom of your
shoe you'll feel the sensation of it but
it doesn't actually hurt you it's pretty
much exactly the same
a giant nail file is actually what we
call a rasp and then you would use the
raft to get it nice and flat because
these horses actually walk on their
fingernails unlike us so this has to be
flat to help them walk evenly on their
joints because if you did one side
higher than the other then they'd be
walking unevenly and it would put
excessive strain on their joints and the
tendons so the idea is to get it as flat
as you can so almost perfect
so say if it wasn't quite 100 perfectly
flat the shoe would actually finish that
job for you
so every foot that i do is completely
unique there's no feet
to the same i buy these sort of factory
made to a standard size and then we put
them in the forge to heat them up to
make them flexible or malleable enough
to make them custom for the horse so the
process would start with getting the
right size of the horse sort by memory
and a lot of practice as you're trimming
the feet you sort of see the the shape
that the horse's feet you have so you
might see it's slightly straight on one
side quite flare on one side you would
clock that in your brain automatically
get a rough size and shape that you
would need and nine times out of ten i
would get it pretty much bang on
straight away
i'm now sort of looking to make sure
that the shoe fits the foot this doesn't
hurt the horse's foot at all if you hold
it on there for a long time then the
sensation of the heat will travel up the
foot they will eventually feel it but
i'd say five six seconds is probably all
you need
and then this will make a mirror image
from the shoe to the foot surface so as
you burn it on it it makes it perfectly
flat so it's not a perfect snug fit
once they're fitted and they're the
right shape for the horse needs you need
to cool them down so a bucket of water
is good old-fashioned way of getting it
down to handling temperature so you can
pick up and use it with your own hands
the nails probably only go about two or
three mil into the hoof wall and then
they'll go up with hoof wood and come
out the side so as you nail it in it
curves out so then you can flick it over
and clamp it onto the foot
and i'm using my clenching tongs so
these actually flick over the end of the
nail and push it back into the foot so
it grips and stays on to create what was
known as clenches and then i'll use
a rasp and that would um buff the foot
up make it all nice and smooth because
you want any sharp edges for the horse
to catch itself so this is the finishing
process to make it all basically nice
and pretty and what people will consider
as part of getting their nails done
really
as you file the hoof wall off you're
actually taking like a very very fine
layer off the outside which maintains
the moisture in the feet and it's not
protective loud so you replenish this
with grease or any oil or anything shiny
really
if you're malnourished or anything like
that fingernails and hair are the first
thing that would show that same as any
animals you know with dogs cats only
that hygiene you know is a big factor if
you've got poor hygiene of a horse you
know in a stable that's not cleaned out
poor maintenance of its feet
not being trimmed or looked after will
eventually affect a horse or any animal
in the wild horses aren't actually meant
to live as long as we allow them to live
normally as they get to an age or it
could be 10 to 15 depending on type
breed environment and the predators they
would naturally have they would slow
down and the predators would get them so
we have them in such good pasture and
maintain them so well they look actually
a lot longer
you